we're asked to select which fractions
add together to make 25 over 22 or 25 20
seconds you can use as many fractions as
you need put all unused fractions into
the trashcan so let's think about how we
could do this so I actually want to use
the largest fraction first just so I can
get pretty close so I'm going to make 16
over 22 and let's see if I add 8 over 22
to that then that's going to get me to
let's see 16 plus 8 that gets me to 24
20 seconds this is 16 20 seconds plus 8
20 seconds is going to give me 24 20
seconds and if I get one more that gets
me to 25 20 seconds and then I could put
these unused ones down here in the
trashcan so I'm going to put these
unused ones down here and let's actually
check our answer got it right and
there's multiple ways there's multiple
ways that we could have actually done
this actually it's not clear that
there's multiple ways that we could have
done this let's see is there any other
way yeah because even if we did even if
we did the 2 and the 4 even if we put
the 2 and the 4 here we would have to
get to see 8 would get us to this is to
20 seconds plus for 20 seconds 6 20
seconds plus 8 20 seconds and be 14 20
seconds yeah and then if you put 16 20
seconds there's going to be too many so
actually the way we did it was the way
that you got to do it so the 2 and the 4
I'm going to put in the trashcan and
16 20 seconds 16 of something plus 1 of
something plus 8 or something it's going
to be 25 of that something and in this
case something that we're talking about
are 20 seconds